how did you finally get caught
i resigned
in 1988. so let's actually talk about
that there was a okay yeah resigned
there's there's warning signs yeah
there's another yet another choice yet
another crossroads yes okay what was the
calculation what was the choice to be
made
to um give a little background uh it was
it was 1988
and i
i was i thought
they would
my
uh
my
time in the us would soon end
because you know i thought 10
to 12 years it was already past 10 years
there was no indication that they
that they indicated you know that they
said you know you know we're done you're
done
but
in december of 1988 i got this one
one thing that i never wanted to see so
we had a system of signals
that uh uh
either
one of those diplomat agents could set
at a spot that i go pass by
every day
or i could set where they would pass by
uh like on their way from where they
live to the united nations for instance
who would just drive
so and and mine was uh
my the signal spot uh for me was
on a on a support beam for the elevated
atrian and in queens
and it was uh
morning in december that i walked by
there and routinely look at it and i
never expected anything and there was
this red dot it was about the size of my
fist with a you know red paint
and uh
you know since you have done it already
i can i think i can curse in this uh
moment because it's the only way i can
really indicate how i felt i said oh
[ __ ]
because that was the danger signal yes
there was like you must you are in
severe danger of uh and you you need to
get out of the country as soon as
possible there was a
a protocol that i was supposed to follow
i wasn't even supposed to go home
i just needed to was supposed to get my
my reserve documents that i had
uh hidden in uh in a park in
in the bronx
and made make a beeline to the canadian
border
i wasn't ready
so i just like ignored this thing i mean
i did i couldn't ignore it but i went on
to work
got on the a train get went to work
and then went to my cubicle and stared
at the computer screen all day because i
couldn't think i could think only about
what to do what to do what to do the
reason for this in indecisiveness was
that
i was a father at the time i was
my my little girl by the name of chelsea
was 18 months old
and
i
was there when she was born
i took her to
tour the home
i watched her grow up i i watched her
take the first steps
and always look at me with these big
eyes lovingly look at me and uh
that is when i started my re-entry
into the human race
because
i just fell in love with this girl
that's when love came back
and it was completely unexpected
and there's a lot of fathers who
understand you
particularly fathers of girls who who
understand what happened there
and
i still thought i need to go back
because you know there was
there was probably some danger but i
hadn't figured out how to take care of
the girl you know
and leave her but you know maybe she
needs to
she need to have a good life and grow up
and
have a chance and
her mother had a she was from south
america she had a fourth grade education
that would have not worked very well
so i
played for time
i
obviously
i could be sick i couldn't you know i
could be in a hospital there was a
precedent where i was sick where i
couldn't communicate for about
three weeks
so
i just
did nothing
that was on a monday on a thursday was
my regular
shortwave transmission
i listened and they explained a little
in in in a few sentences we have reason
to believe that the fbi is on your case
you need to uh execute the emergency
procedure
come home right away
i still had some time because the radio
could be broken or the
transmission was bad or he still could
be in a hospital right so
i gave myself some more time
and then
something happened
where
they forced my hand it's the only time
that the soviet agent was anywhere near
me on the territory of the united states
so i'm waiting for the a train on a
on a
dark morning still in
in queens and
there's this uh
man the short man in a black trench coat
comes up to me from my right
and he whispers into my ears
you gotta come back
or else you're dead
i can't imitate the russian accent there
was a russian accent so
now
and it was a pretty strong accent
the you're dead phrase
can have two meanings
and an american would have said
or else you're busted or else you get
arrested or else you're dead it's very
strong
so now
you have to have to take it seriously to
some degree because i knew that
they didn't they had a history of uh
assassinating or at least trying to
assassinate the factor so
uh that that obviously raised the the
stakes a little bit uh but i i i just
talked myself into believing this was
just uh bad phrasing
and uh but at this point
i knew and they knew that we both knew
right so there was no more guessing he
he found me he talked to me i know
so now i had to act so in in the next
radiogram i was uh
asked for uh to
execute a dead drop operation where
they would give me money
and uh
a passport
and that was in a park in on staten
island
it was a location that i found
and i described
and i was always
praised for
my ability to describe spots that are
easy to find
so that what that was a given so
and the only thing that was different in
this for this operation they scheduled
it for the dark
all right so but
it was still no problem because it was
in a park and then a couple of um about
uh
a hundred yards in uh by uh next to a a
fallen tree
it would be hard to miss so i go to
staten island and i read the signal that
uh said uh you i i put the container in
the drop
that that was the protocol there's a
signal that the person who
uh who
hands over with something
puts at a spot not too far from the spot
itself
that means
i would go in and just pick it up the
reason i actually
uh
went
to pick up this container because there
was money in it so i didn't have to make
a decision yet
okay i could throw away the passport i
it was like i was still trying to figure
out what to do what to do what to do
so i get to the spot i get to the tree
uh and i
had a flashlight with me that the park
there was nowhere in the park and it was
even during the day this park was not uh
it was more almost like a little forest
and uh
i don't see the container it wasn't
supposed to be in a crushed oil can
pretty sizable nothing hard to miss
and i do a double take and i look again
and i look around and look around a
little more see if they misplaced it
i can't find it
that's the only one that one of those
operations failed
and
that just doesn't make a lot of sense
so when as i'm walking away from this
like sort of
emotionally
i said to myself i'm
staying yeah
that decision kind of signals some kind
of
muse just spoke to you that decision
[Music]
was made for me now you know that i'm a
christian now and i think that was like
god told me this you know
but it was certain there it was right
there that was it that was it that was
it and uh so what i did uh
uh to
uh well first of all i
uh i'm divine into intervention helped
me to find find a good
explanation i sent them my last letter
and with secret writing
i uh
i communicated to them i said i i wish i
could come but i can't because i have
contracted hiv aids
that was the best lie ever
because
nobody wanted to have aids in their
country those days it was a death
sentence right yes and i knew i had we
had conversations
when i was back in moscow how they were
snickering about what's going on in the
united states you know that that
depraved culture and you see when they
they're killing each other and the
debrief culture took you took over your
being and yeah you're saying no and and
i was and i was convincing enough i'd
even traced it back to
a girlfriend i had once that i had
actually reported on that she you know i
i interacted with this lady who
had a boyfriend
at one point uh who was a drug addict
and she was infected and she infected me
so
they believed it they sent and i asked
him to
give my my dollar savings to my german
family uh
they gave them some but they
they told they told my family that i
already passed away that i'm dead
they believed it 100
and
i guess the agent who
took the money took half of it for
himself
so that was it and uh
the next three months i made sure that i
wasn't
uh reliably
at the same spot
in the same time frame
so i went to work in different
paths at different times
just to you know
just doing
safety measures so to speak and not not
not huge uh but you know i did it
it kept me kept
allowed me to keep my sanity
uh and and obviously after i
sent the letter i i threw the shortwave
radio in the hudson river
destroyed the one-time pads that i still
had so i was now
uh ready to uh for a new life for a new
life and live out my life as an american
undiscovered uh but you know
starting to work on my version of the
american dream
and
the first action was was i was telling
my wife the mother of this child
you know she always
wanted to have a house and say you know
what we should buy a house
and a year later we moved into the
suburbs and then i said we should have
another child and we had another child
so and i had a career where i did pretty
well
uh
i moved
a couple of times wound up in a mech
mansion
before that
my second house was actually in
pennsylvania in rural pennsylvania and
this is
uh where
uh
i was discovered by the fbi
and how did they know about me i i if if
it if it hadn't been for this defector
vasily mitrokin who was an archivist in
in the kgb archives
he was actually pretty high level he was
in charge of the relocation of the
archive
from
lupianka to yasinovo
and he really hated the
he had reason to believe he hated the
soviet system
i i think i remember that his son was
quite ill and he could have gotten
treatment in england and he was not
allowed to
to uh travel to england with his son so
he
uh his hatred he tried to figure out
what to do and how to do damage to that
system so he started copying notes
little
little slips of paper
handwritten that he smuggled out in his
underwear and in socks
over the years
and then he transcribed them with the
typewriter and then put
the
pieces of paper uh
and into some kind of a container and
and and
buried this in a starch on
it was i believe in 1992
when he showed up that was already the
the soviet union was gone
so he showed up at the u.s embassy in
moscow and told him what he had and
it was on a weekend and apparently there
was a junior person in charge and he
said you know what what you got we are
not interested in it's really old
[Laughter]
that's a career limiting move right uh
because then
vasily mitrokin then
made its way to
one of the baltic republics and
contacted mi6
and they said come on in north fellow
have a cup of tea
and so they they managed to get this
stuff out of the dacha and uh and get it
to england and eventually
uh the mi6 shared it with the fbi and uh
there wasn't a whole lot of information
about me it was very very little it was
like there's an a person by the name of
jack barsky who
isn't illegal
operating in the northeast of the united
states now if it was jim miller they
wouldn't have found me jack barsky was
easy to find
so they checked social security and jack
barsky was uh
had gotten his uh his social security
card at the age of 33.
bingo okay
though all they knew though was that i
wasn't illegal that i was still living
there they didn't know whether i was
active inactive
uh they and the other thing that they
knew that i was a really really
well-trained agent because i was still
there right
so um they took uh
i think almost three years to
investigate me watch me from a distance
because you know if i was still
active i would would have found out that
somebody is
investigating here so you started being
less and less active in terms of uh oh i
stopped completely
what i mean is oh oh surveillance detect
remote yes
actions after three months i stopped all
together okay yeah good point and fbi
still be very careful they were very
careful they they pretty much watched me
and and at one point
i had a house in the country with one
neighbor at one point that house was for
sale so the fbi bought it
and they put a couple of agents there
and just keep a closer eye on me
there was no
indication that
uh i was still active but they were
still cautious
and
but at one point they
they were able to plant a bug in my
kitchen a listening device
and
i
my wife and i
didn't get along very well you know
there was a lot of friction and she was
constantly complaining about things and
you know i got sick and tired of it and
one day we had an argument in the
kitchen
and then i i
chose to
deploy the nuclear option
and that is that is telling her
what i sacrificed to be with her to so
she would understand that
i am there on her side yeah i'm
supporting her if something doesn't
quite fit it is not because i don't love
the both of them chelsea
and penelope
so
i when i said that
the listening device was active so the
fbi was
hearing my confession
i was once a kgb agent blah blah blah
blah and and i quit because
uh
then because of uh and then state state
here because of you and
chelsea
and um
that also
made it clear to the fbi that i wasn't
active anymore so they had both of that
so
now uh they knew
an attempt to turn me would have been
useless because you know
because you know you turned somebody was
active
but they figured they had
there was enough reason to treat me
nicely because
they figured that i had a lot of
information
that
was as as aged as it was but it was
still important for the fbi to get to
know
and so
one day
there was a friday
evening i
driving back home from the office
and i'm being stopped by a um
state
state
state police
and
as i'm going through the toll
uh oh that it's a bridge over the hudson
and they had to pay a toll
and he waved me he got me right
where i stopped and he said could you
please uh
move over here it's a routine traffic
stop and i thought nothing of it i i had
forgotten at that point that i
once was a spy you know it was like this
was gone
and uh
and then he said no could you sleep
please step out of the car that should
have uh aroused my suspicion that's
unusual right routine traffic stop
uh yeah i did it no problem and then
again somebody came from the right came
into my view and he flipped this uh
id and i said fbi we would like to have
a talk with you
you know this is uh my now friend joe
riley who
who actually is uh the uh he's the
godfather of my of trinity my last child
but anyway
uh he told me later that
when when
i heard that phrase
all the blood left my face it became
totally white
but i recovered very quickly and he said
it himself so you know he they took me
to
a vehicle
and
there was an another agent in
the vehicle and he had a gun strapped to
his ankle so
that was pretty real
first question i had so am i under
arrest and the answer was no
and then
my instinct kicked in
uh in my ability to to operate in a very
well under high pressure situations and
i asked them so what took you so long
you know
the intent of that was to
um
to
the
diffuse any kind of tension
yes and i saw a smile
instant friends uh yeah i knew i knew
that
i had to make them
like me
and i'm
i think by now i know i'm a pretty
pretty likable person so i would say so
so so uh and i uh when when they took me
to a motel which they had rented uh
there was an uh
the two two uh wings at a right angle
they they had one they bought all the
rooms in one wing and they had a guard
at each end of
that wing and they took me in the middle
and there were some props there
some binders with labels
and
i i immediately thought now this is
really silly because
but what i know what i noticed that the
own the labels all referred back to my
early years i knew that they didn't know
much else
so um i told joe that afterwards and
that was not a great idea but anyway
[Laughter]
uh but but i volunteered i made the
following statement before we even
started the the uh interview i said i
know there's only one way for me to and
my family
to have a chance to get through here
without much damages if i'm if i'm
completely 100 percent cooperative and
this is my intent
to do
exactly that
all right so
we spent about two hours in the
interview they allowed me to call my
wife
tell her that i'm going to be late that
indicated to me already that they would
let me go and after two hours they let
me go
but they had
the area
covered with a whole bunch of people and
the head of that
that team talked to me and said if you
think
of running
we got every intersection in this area
covered you can't
i didn't say anything but you know i had
no no thought of running
so and that was the beginning
of uh
another phase of my life where i was on
cooperating with the fbi for quite a
while and living still undercover for
several years until i had real good
documentation
and became an american citizen uh seven
years ago
uh today seven years ago so recently uh
yeah wow quite recent the bureaucracy
took a long time to figure out how to
how to make me
real and
and also not put me in
in in this witness protection program
you know to keep my name
and then just you know make
everything like official so for instance
i had to change my birth year
uh simply because if i
jack barsky was born in 1944 if i kept
1944 the fbi would have helped me commit
a crime because i would have
collected social security of uh four
years or sooner
so and anyway uh details of that yes it
it took quite a while and when i finally
got the call from
the office uh of homeland security
uh uh
the lady says uh this is agent so and so
uh
uh from
homeland security
can you come to the office tomorrow
and uh
i said um let me look at my calendar and
then i said wait a minute what am i
talking about what time do you want me
to be there because i had waited for
that moment for a long time and i was
sworn in right then and there
it was a good feeling to walk out of
there because i
i had a country again
you know and i love this country just as
much as you said you love it uh
with all its warts and its problems that
we're going through right now um
and
then
the last thing that changed my life
again and i don't want to get into
details because it's a little
complicated story i never wanted to
be a public person
uh and then
i was discovered through a number of uh
dots that were unlikely to be connected
it had to do with a relative with with a
half brother of my wife
who lives
in germany
uh was taken to uh to
germany by his mother
who came to visit somebody not us
but that somebody that he came to visit
uh lived 50 miles from our house
and that my my wife and and this half
brother never
never met in person before they knew
about each other through social media
and when he found out my background he
he was a
conductor who was a german railroad at
the time
he said oh this is a big story one
that's gonna be big big big
okay
well he happened to know this one person
who happened happened to know uh
uh one of the star reporters of der
spiegel
and uh after she did some research and
determined that
i was real
she was on my case and she happened to
know
uh steve croft the guy uh guy from 60
minutes you see all these connections i
had nothing to do with it that's how
life works dots get connected somehow
sometimes yeah most of us it does stuff
happens
you get lucky you you don't know about
the lucky a few times in your life but
yeah i think i'm
must be part irish too
[Laughter]
yeah so uh it's uh it's been it's been
an interesting ride
um
i'm just
still shaking my head about all the
stuff that happened
you